why is it that when you build a
technologically sophisticated telescope
that can peer out into the vast depths
of space that you're also looking back
in time so all telescopes are time
machines of A Sort and that's by virtue
of the fact that light as fast as it
travels and it is the fastest
propagating entity that we know about in
all of science it travels about this far
about one foot every nanosecond if you
convert nanoseconds to Miles and you
convert a feet to miles and nanoseconds
to seconds it travels about 186 000
miles per second which is pretty darn
fast but it's not infinite so therefore
whenever you're looking at something
you're not seeing it as it is right now
you're seeing it as it was sometime in
the past and the farther away something
is the longer the light travel to reach
your eyes or to reach our telescopes